go away quand même la compétition 6 6 6
kg bat java nous fait pas honte
on va démarrer par dylan et après kelly
le fera d'accord attention dylan tu vas
est chronométrée est ce que tu connais
le parcours dylan tu dois passer là tu
passe en dessous tac tac tac tac tu vas
là tu vas encore en dessous la poutre et
après tu passe là bas comme on dit la
nasa qui est un aventurier talents
lèvent tout ce que tu veux sauf ton slip
d'accord moi je dis non merci on a été
bon et beau tylane trochon celle bien
attention mondiale thé près d'eux
il est très fort
non mais là tout ce qu'il fallait
[Musique]
très simple dylan j'ai presque envie se
dire est ce qu'on a besoin d'eux on va
voir ce que ça donne
attention attention je crois à moi la
bonne affaire 13 secondes toutes fleurs
de tulle invasion où elle arrive à 13
secondes à 13 soit avec du stock
[Rires]
c'est terminé merci à toi c'est quoi un
criquet à la salle jean verdier là ils
sont très forts les bétonneuses attendez
attendez ça va jouer alors attention
quand vous êtes égalité attention tu
dises et vous finissez à la photo ou la
polo
merci quoi de réforme il est très fort
comme si tu est exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
jean michel mr law après quand même la
compétition 6 6 6 kg benjamin nous fait
pas honte à dos à la page 6 kg au bout
de moi si ça roule bien pour l'instant
ça roule bien
bravo on arrive à droite dylan 23 ans 1
3 ans du luxembourg
si les boutons pourtant tout voir bouton
pour moi
attention pardon pardon au sol est ce
important pour la ménagère
[Musique]
olivier 43 c'est bon ça marche mais
gmail
c'est important pour toutes les
personnes âgées qui nous regardent
jamais sûr par sow à la tension
[Applaudissements]
à jouer
regardez
[Musique]